就是最近大概一个礼拜的时间，
然后知道了我老公那边就是输了那个很多很多钱，
多了很多钱，
他是被人做局了，
还是他自己主动喜欢干这个事儿，
我也不太清楚，
因为因为今年我没有跟他在一起，
可能是两边，
然后我是带着孩子在这边的公司，
我们自己跟别人合伙的，
公司这边的客户之前一直在这边，
我们两个一直在这边，
是今年5月份他出去的，
然后我是最近才知道这边事的，
就是除了房子，
然后车也被抵押了，
房也被抵押了，
车也被抵押了，
是吧，
房子没有，
房子是在我的名字下，
但是房子总共就是我们在自己家那边买的房子不值钱，
现在还有几十万的贷款，
嗯，
公司这边也就是说如果我不做了退股的话，
也分不到什么钱，
因为他结了一些公司的钱去用，
就相当于股份，
可能就抵掉这边的钱，
还有贷款，
贷款应该就是跟我都有关系，
因为之前是因为要开公司，
然后贷的款你都签字了是吧？
对贷了多少啊，
总共银行是350，
他现在输了多少，
你具体知道吗？
我不知道，
他也没跟你说输了多少是吧，
对，
那现在这银行这350万，
你们这个公司现在就是说。
净资产还能从公司里面变现出来多少钱呀，
自由钱，
好，
那你告诉我，
你名下这套房值多少钱呀？
啊，
不值钱，
现在啊，
是多，
我来问问你，
你们两口子有孩子吗？
小多大了，
他没有上幼儿园，
大的上小学，
小学啊，
然后你的父母是干什么的？
娘家哦，
我爸爸妈妈那边没有办法帮我们，
她的爸爸妈妈是干啥的？
他爸爸在家里开一个小公司小厂，
他是独生子吗？
我是有一个妹妹，
有一个妹妹啊，
然后他的爸爸妈妈大概收入怎么样，
家庭资产怎么样啊，
我婆婆在这边帮我带小孩，
我公公一年可能也就是几十个，
也就可能四五十，
最多最多这样子哦，
那现在那个车抵押的贷款你也跟他签字了吗？
车子是他自己私自把它卖掉的哦，
车里方已经卖掉了，
那个车卖掉了多少钱呀，
这个钱已经不在了，
那现在就是说你跟他共同签字的是350万的这个贷款，
然后呢，
他如我这个信用卡也在他那里，
那你信用卡的额度是多少呀，
我信用卡有四张，
应该有20多万哦，
这信用卡也被他都花花爆了是不是对好，
那你现在希望鸿飞帮你分析的问题是什么呀？
就是我我出人就比较明白，
我已经申请了，
就到过年的时候可能就分开，
然后就是对于两个小孩子，
我不知道怎么去处理，
自己是以前干过啥买卖，
干过啥工作，
你自己的赚钱能力怎么样啊？
嗯，
之前是财务，
然后后面到了这边之后，
就是这边就是厂里一直是我在管啊，
这个是公共的厂啊，
还是你们两口子的厂，
如果我们跟别人合伙开的啊，
你们跟别人合伙开的这个厂。
这个厂现在将来他的预期的盈利状况怎么样呢？
行情不好，
建筑行业哦，
我不打算做了，
就是股东知道了这个事之后，
就在第二天立马就把公司的股权全部都变掉了，
然后收收款码什么的全部都变掉了，
然后反正就我自己在这边，
然后对我说话也是那种阴阳怪气的，
我觉得干不下去，
因为人家股东也怕被连累嘛，
看你老公他的一些债主介上门来的时候，
怕影响到公司嘛，
你跟他提分手，
你们已经去申请了，
你的老公他也答应了是不是不答应，
只是说这小孩儿该怎么安排，
你没想好是不是？
嗯，
这小孩这俩就是你，
你觉得谁更需要你一点呢？
嗯，
系统不知道怎么说，
他们两个都是我带在这边呢，
你假设你跟他分开了之后，
你住哪儿呢？
是回娘家吗？
那你跟他提分手的时候，
他愿意把那个房子给你吗？
那他随便问，
但是我不知道能不能保得住呀，
这事儿是这样子的啊，
你们共同签的那个350万那个贷款，
那个事儿是就算你俩分开了也躲不掉，
但是他的，
哎，
他债这事儿的话，
有可能能躲得掉，
他还借了一些亲戚朋友的钱，
那你现然在在那个协议里面明确的写，
他当时问那个亲戚借的钱，
这个钱他用来干嘛了，
没有用于夫妻共同的生活，
所以呢，
这个钱将来他自己来偿还，
与你无关，
应该写清楚，
这个我跟他讲过，
他也同意的，
我就是我不知道这个房子会不会被起诉，
你们签的那个350万的那个事儿，
那肯定如果说欠的是银行的钱的话，
肯定是要被那个啥的被追诉的，
所以这个房子的话也无所谓，
如果被起诉就被起诉，
结果给我也没有办法，
姐妹只能这么跟你聊天了啊，
嗯，
就算有一天被起诉了，
就算有一天还不上了，
就算有一天因为这350万的债务上了黑名单了，
但是咱们日子还得往下过，
因为孩子还小，
孩子还需要我们日子往下怎么过呢？
咱说句难听点的话，
嗯，
哪怕说去吃个摊，
摆个摊儿，
咱弄点什么手艺，
卖点什么吃的。
咱们可以给小孩儿申请一个微信吗？
给小孩儿申请一张卡吗？
我话只能点到这儿了，
你明白吗？
就是就算有一天因为银行那350万还不上了，
咱们日子还得往下过，
只不过你不能坐飞机，
不能坐高铁，
其他的生活还得继续啊，
养孩子该养还得养是吧，
孩子一天一天还得长大，
但是信用卡的目前我也还不了，
那是一个意思，
信用卡还不上和北银行350万还不上是一个意思啊，
都是说黑名单，
呃，
我现在是在外地嘛，
在外地我想着今年把厂里清算了以后，
然后呃回就是我公公婆婆那边，
他们的意思就是他们帮我带着孩子，
让我去开个店或者是上班，
然后因为我担心他说他每天帮我接送，
然后就是说叫我，
我管一下小孩子教育方面的事，
他们是跟我这样说啊，
那那也可以，
那也挺好的啊，
那咱们就暂定先这么往前推进，
嗯，
该分开咱们就分开，
该把这个房子归你就归你，
该把债务写清楚写清楚，
由他来偿还，
咱们就写清楚，
真到有一天信用卡还不上了，
银行那350万还不上了，
咱们就做好这样的充分的思想准备，
日子还得继续往下过，
就是很担心别人会起诉，
担心这事儿必然的就是对不起啊，
就这事儿别人起。
所以这是必然的啊，
你因为银行欠银行的钱，
他不起诉你的话，
他就违法了，
所以他起诉你这是个必然的动作，
就是咱们就做好这样的思想准备迎接，
就这意思，
我就跟你多说两句啊，
我以前也上过黑名单，
也是坐不了飞机，
坐不了高铁，
但是我的心态就是甭管怎么样，
我都得好好活着，
只要我活着就有机会，
其实如果是我己的话，
就是我是完全有能力，
就是就算是教我养两个孩子，
我觉得我也可以的，
因为我住济南这边，
我管一个我们厂，
我也好几年，
我感觉就是我我随便去开一个什么店，
或者是我去上班，
我现在在这个厂里不做了，
我手里有这么多客户，
我就在这周边的这些厂，
我就跟他们随便到哪个厂里去做销售，
我就跟他们说，
我手里有这些客户，
我都可以拿到一个不错的工资，
我觉得这事儿咱们要面对现实，
在哪儿能挣钱多就在哪待，
嗯，
尊重你自己的这个意愿啊，
然后总体的思路咱们就是做好心理准备。
该面对就面对，
日子还得照常过，
那他这个对小孩子上学有什么妨碍吗？
第一任意你别想那么多姑娘，
因为小孩儿以后工作，
首先九年义务教育是不受影响的，
其次她要是考高中啊什么的也不受影响，
他只要不是上那种什么特别贵的私立小学都不受影响。
我跟你说啊，
现在对于小孩子啊，
反正龙菲姐我今天就那个多说两句，
对于小孩子来说，
最主要的是培养他自己那个良好的性格，
与人交往的能力，
他自己自立自强，
哪怕是学一门手艺，
他自己自洽，
他通过自己的手艺，
通过自己的双手，
他劳动，
他能赚到钱，
他自洽，
最主要的是这一点，
好，
我我知道，
嗯，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
反正我自己现在心心态是这样子的，
我对待我自己的小孩儿，
就是从小就是让他自己刻意的培养他自己，
接纳他自己，
如果他是一个聪明的人，
他去接纳自己，
如果他是一个平凡的人，
他学习成绩不好，
他接纳了他自己。
嗯，
如果他是一个非常非常有欲望，
对赚钱很有欲望的人好，
他就努力去赚钱，
如果他是一个呃，
得过且过，
他不是那么很努力的想要赚钱，
不是那么很努力的想要开好的车，
那他接纳他自己就挺好，
但因为你看到现在很多卷生卷死啊，
就送孩子去这读书，
去那读书，
去这读书去那读书，
他孩子毕业出来了之后，
他未必。
开心啊，
孩子毕业了出来，
他哪怕去投行，
哪怕去很好的律师事务所，
哪怕去很高级的那个办公室，
他也未必能自洽，
未必能开心，
未必能够幸福的度过他的一生，
他可能会成长为一个非常极端的人啊，
在情感当中对吧，
换各种各样的女朋友，
或者换各种各样的男朋友，
在不同的女朋友之间游走，
去体会那种一遍一遍的从别人对他的那个态度当中去体，
体会到那种快乐幸福什么的，
到最后都是一场空，
他可能就变成那样了，
压力又不大，
就是从现在开始，
就是观察自己的孩子，
接纳自己的孩子，
让自己的孩子学会接纳他自己。